what you doing later
[Applause]
you're flirting with sharon and you want
to fight me what kind of show is this
guys
sharon osbourne shamelessly flirting
with the frog on the mask singer at this
point
apparently anything goes on this show
right it's a singing competition but
it's also
a dating show i'm here for it give me
all the genres
of what's up you guys welcome back to
unmasking the math singer
we're still at home i'm deidre behar i'm
charlie o'keefe
we're thrilled to have you here with us
we're gonna break down a whole new set
of clues in tonight's episode
and listen we were both head over peels
for tonight's eliminated performer
but before we get into his unmasking
let's take a look at his song choices
tonight
mama she put my guns in the ground
great michael oh come on
[Music]
ring ring ring ring
hello oh oh hey deedra uh i just called
to let you know
that we've been right all along and
sharon osbourne is on our team
with brett michaels as the banana well
how about that
charlie oh you apparently hung up your
banana thought sorry
that is right sadly the banana has got
rotten
and left the competition take a look
and roll superstar i gotta tell you i
would have done
anything to get here this is the most
awesome show
i've never had such a great time oh rock
legend
brett michaels arguably i think he had
more fun with this show than maybe any
other contestant
we've seen so far you can tell that
being a part of the mass singer
meant a lot to him not only because he's
like such a seasoned performer
but because you know he's also overcome
so many things in his life
how did you feel about it and i think
him being a musician was something
different i mean we see people who we
don't normally see sing come on the show
and kind of go crazy
rob gronkowski who is a performer who
takes the show seriously and really gets
up there that each week and gives a
concert performance if you will
yeah he worked the crowd it was so cool
to see him play piano tonight and and
actually on a sentimental note it's the
10-year anniversary today
of brett's brain hemorrhage and so the
fact that he played a song like
knocking on heaven's door i feel like he
was really trying to send a message and
you can tell he's just so happy
to be here to be alive to be singing and
doing fun things like the mass singer
you go bret michaels i'm gonna salute
you
i'm not gonna say i foreshadowed this a
bit but like everyone else on day 5000
of quarantine
i baked banana bread today and
i was baking it and i thought what if
the banana goes home tonight
and i'm sad to say it happened wow
channeling your inner raven simone you
had a premonition
i did i had a premonition i had a vision
well listen deidra i
told you that the next performer was
gonna bring his a-game tonight like
every other week
let's take a look at the frog toad you
i was born
my mother said that everyone wouldn't
know my name
charlie you know in life i'm passionate
about a few things
pitbull and reggaeton music being two of
them
uh imagine how excited i was when i was
at home in my living room by myself
dancing to the frog's performance
so much energy so much passion and like
he said in his package tonight
what he may lack in like big grand vocal
ability
he more than makes up for with these
really high energy performances did you
like it
i listen mr worldwide mr 305 like
that is a great song choice to do
pitbull and like you said what he can't
do vocally he makes up
again giving us a full dance performance
on that stage that you can't look away
from
1 000 so let's get right into tonight's
clue packages we got to see
more of the whole tsa themed exposed
suitcases that is right and we are
sticking with our original guest
as bow wow for the frog and i think we
got some great clues tonight that
secured the bag
all right so we saw some sneakers in his
luggage bag on the stage uh bow wow is
in fact a sneaker head he's done
shopping for sneaker videos on youtube
he's posted about his sneakers before
makes sense there also we saw a japanese
flag which kind of threw me for a second
i was like oh just has he performed in
japan
well bow wow is also the name of a very
influential
japanese rock band formed in 1976 so not
quite the same bow wow we know but still
the name oh wow
i would like to go see them link up and
do a duet it feels very natural at this
point right
what do you think the other big thing
that i picked up on was the ice cube
tray
okay so follow me here bow wow he
starred in
the 2010 comedy lottery ticket
of course opposite ice cube makes sense
to me doesn't that work yes
i think we're sticking with bow wow
through and through here for this one
totally
well guys the kitty was looking good and
feline
fine during tonight's two performances
take a look
well the kitty who we're still sticking
with jackie ivanko
she's been wonderful every single week
but i really loved this week because we
got two performances we got a signature
ballad and then we also got more of like
a pop power anthem
so you know she had said in her clue
package i am not the seasoned performer
she knows that she's really a
balladeer in that sense but i feel like
she really commanded the stage and she
is hustling this season what did you
think
and i like that about the smackdown
rounds i think we normally get a
different
song choice from them when they when
they're fighting for to keep their mask
on there
and in her luggage tonight we saw some
interesting things the first being that
i picked up on
the pope's hat yes we saw the the holy
pope hat
in her luggage jack ivanka actually sang
for pope francis during his u.s
visit in 2015 in philadelphia so that
kind of
came from me there deep research well
i'm not gonna lie i'm pretty proud that
we decoded this one there was a dragon
in her suitcase
and you know whenever i see dragons i
immediately think game of thrones
someone who was on game of thrones
but actually jackie dropped a video for
her song
the reigns of castamere and if you
follow the narrative of the video by the
end you see these silhouettes
of dragons that are like breathing fire
it's very dramatic
so i feel like it has to signify that
single right yeah girl likes her dragons
she threw it i'm gonna go
through him and her bad clue it makes
sense to me live your best mystical life
jackie ivanko
so as charlie and i were watching
tonight's episode we
both immediately seamlessly texted one
another
when nicole scherzinger had a very
interesting way of of telling the world
that she thought the kitty
was emma roberts take a look at
tonight's reality check
[Music]
uh let's see who is on the cast of ugly
dirt
oh scoops it could be
emma roberts so in that brief moment
there we got a little cardi b
action we got nicole talking in her own
invented language
i'm i'm here for all those wild nicole
moments
they're truly the highlight of each
episode
well our final math singer of the night
is truly one horn ahead of his
competitors
check it out
[Music]
well we are still guessing everyone's
favorite main course especially ours
barry tortellini aka
former mlb pro turned country singer
barry zito will we affectionately call
barry tortellini thumbs up if you love
barry tortellini as much as charlie and
i do
our dear friend the rhino's luggage was
exposed and the first big clue that
really caught my attention
was the little sign that said ry no
secrets and of course barry cedo being
the country star that he is he dropped
his very first ep in 2017 what was it
called
no secrets there it is we saw some
really interesting things
in his luggage aside from that luggage
tag we also saw a tennessee flag
after uh playing in the mlb
professionally he moved down to
tennessee
which is where he settled down to focus
on his music
we also saw a seal i guess you could say
he was in his sunday best he was kind of
cartoon seal wearing a little bow tie uh
barry zito and his wife amber
actually partnered with a foundation
called easter seals which gives back and
helps military veterans
i love that he's a country star he's a
philanthropist he's a former mlb pro and
now
we like to think he's on the math singer
i i hope we are proven right here i
think we will be
i think so too and it's crazy to think
we're really
getting down to the wire these episodes
are slowly coming to an end
but charlie and i of course will be here
to take you through all of it before
though
very exciting announcement tomorrow
charlie and i
will both be interviewing brett michaels
himself we're gonna ask him all the
behind the scenes scoop
about his experience on the mass singer
and uh lord knows a whole lot more we
got a lot prepared for him so stay tuned
for that interview
tomorrow on etonline.com but also on i'm
asking the mass singer next week
that's right i want to know if he kept
those gold high top shoes that
the banana costume wears i'm obsessed
with that i can only
hope he put in so much work he deserves
a shoe as a souvenir
that is right and next week we are back
with the let's call them the
sensational six uh we got the astronaut
the kitty the rhino
frog turtle and night angel all battling
it out next week in their own
performances
trying to make it into the top five i
love it the pressure's on
it's getting harder and harder but we
will never ever stop decoding clues and
trying to figure out who's behind the
mask
stay safe stay healthy i'm deidre behar
i'm charlie o'keefe and we'll see you
guys next week
can i get some of that banana bread oh
yeah here you go